I'm Carson Daly your host to the next
few minutes here with me
The Voice coaches the great when Stefani
John Legend picks up and of course Kelly
Clarkson also joining us in his booth
backstages comedian and celebrity voice
impersonator Josh Robert Thompson hi
Josh it is time to play guess the famous
voice famous voice coaches the game is
very simple he's got two teams boys
versus girls Kelly and Glen which one
they're gonna be playing for all the
ladies in the audience Blake Jon without
me playing for the men in the audience
and we're sending the winning team home
with the new Yamaha why is 109 soundbar
josh is going to do a celebrity
impression if the coaches think they
know the voice that he's doing though
just hit their button they are allowed
to ask the famous voice one questions
you can ask the famous voice of a
question alright then you've got a guest
of another show who it is in my play if
you're right you get a point if you're
wrong the other team can ask a question
and steal all right okay no Josh let's
start this up here we go Josh who is our
first famous voice well let me tell you
something first of all of all the
morning
[Applause]
[Laughter]
alright guys let's get to it who's our
next famous voice come on I'm just
sitting back here with my shirt off
playing bongos I sure didn't I'm smoking
something Mike
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
girls bit of a button hog over here but
here we go
who's our next famous voice now listen
boys I want to let you know that I was
this John Legend
Morgan Morgan Freeman that was that was
amazing say that I will narrate you my
food Morgan what did you do Morgan what
did you do after you got out of
Shawshank after I got out of Shawshank I
bought me some penguins just followed
them around and I narrated them gosh
who's next
hey look guys y'all know I'm a rapper
man I'm a rapper okay that's what I do
and I don't make me bring back the
mullet okay I'm not playing around I'll
do it I'll bring back the mullet I'll do
it wait wait let's deliberate and I need
your final answer wait let's ask one
question okay Cyrus no do you know
that's mine you don't do you have a
daughter in music do i yeah do you have
a daughter that's really popular in
music no no I don't know you I don't
know when why all this do you have a
girlfriend on the boy and super hot you
know I do
[Applause]
I was good so excited for myself that I
got one Josh do you call restaurants and
get good seating because your Blake
Shelton yeah sure man yeah no I get all
the best seating yeah no I really I will
pay you an ungodly amount of money to
bring them all up back he's gonna do it
okay
all right we've got time for one more
final voice this one is worth 20 points
Josh that's like family for you to last
you are you are you talking to me are
you talking to me oh I'm thinking of you
Kelly hits the button I mean were you in
a movie called falling in love with
Meryl Streep Wow falling that's a that's
a deep cut that is a deep cut okay were
you in Meet the Fockers yes I was
[Applause]
robertson here the girls on the winners
[Applause]
because i'm not because i did not cheat
they did not tell me i would never ask
you a question go when you do this show
so y'all go over what the how that wants
to happen during producing exactly in
the briefing which actually this is the
only show I didn't have a briefing for
her but in the briefing it didn't say
anything it just said they'll ask a
question here then the answer and the
answer oh yes personal special script
without show everyone's a winner so
you're all going home with the Yamaha
[Applause]
control music streaming services and 3d
surround sound this is awesome
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this